[Musik]
das klappt jetzt bekommen baden ein
video
ja ich freue mich kriegt die spielzeug
zu drehen also natürlich freue ich mich
immer aber heute freue ich mich ganz
besonders weil ich habe das ganze schon
mal gemacht vor zehn monaten oder so und
ich habe gestern dieses video gefunden
und hatte gedacht er alex kommen machte
daraus einfach im zweiten part oder am
dritten tag gleich mittlerweile schon
ist auf jeden fall mehrere bei euch
angekommen und zwar ab dass er
wahrscheinlich auch schon unten artikel
gelesen es geht heute mal wieder um so
richtig dumme photoshop gehört weil in
diesen zehn monaten sind natürlich neue
bilder aufgetaucht und ja ich habe mir
ein paar rausgesucht die sonnenseite
zusammen und ich hoffe es gefällt ich
würde sagen bei 13.500 leicht kommt noch
mit folge davon
deswegen werner bock drauf ab platz nach
oben da und schickt mir auf jeden fall
weitere fotos die ich noch nicht kenne
fenster das netzwerk einfach mal kurz
eingeblendet
sorry dass jeder so lange str kauft
meine klamotten nicht passt muss
natürlich nicht sofort auf link in der
beschreibung und wir fangen jetzt an
diesem bild romane wir fangen erst mal
sehr prominent an und zwar ist dass
irgendeine kardashian ich kenne mich da
überhaupt nicht aus aber es ist wohl
irgend eine davon und jetzt fragen sich
wahrscheinlich so die ersten von euch
die meine alten videos dazu gar nicht
kennen
ja und was soll damit jetzt sein seit
ich sie mal kurz dran ist auch genau das
äußere von der tür ist so ein bisschen
gewöhnt und ich glaube türen sind
normalerweise nicht gewollt ich weiß
ganz genau wo ich mich frage diese
kardashians die haben doch eh schon so
dicken ashtons jetzt mal so ausdrücken
kann wieso wollen die dänen noch größer
machen das machst du gar keinen sinn ich
mein oder liebe kardashian familie ich
weiß ihr guckt wahrscheinlich alle meine
videos ihr müsst ja gar nicht
vorgeschoben das sieht schon so gut aus
er ließ wirkte machen weiter mit dem
nächsten das ist jetzt zwar erst mal ein
typ so aber es ist halt auch in köln
raus und an sich ist es so schlecht das
ist schon wieder witze hierfür ich meine
wenn ich mir das angucken so er dachte
ich so gut klappt hat der typ
sicherstellen pc gesetzt doch eine
hübsche frau neben sich gesetzt auf
jeden fall von der farbabstimmung passt
das eins zu eins
wann ist das schlecht ich komme ich klar
wollen die frau die sitzt du eigentlich
ja praktisch vor ihm
ihre haare sind ja vor und macht alles
gar keinen sinn die perspektive
stimmlich und die farbabstimmung erst
recht nicht geil
so bekommt zum nächsten bild und wenn
ihr euch das jetzt anschaut werde
wahrscheinlich erst mal denken na gut
das steht heute eine frau im tor hat ein
spanisches trikot an
ein geschieht das gut aus wo ist da
jetzt der fällt ich musste auf oder drei
mal hingucken bis sich gezeigt hat was
auf die sind hingegangen haben gesagt
haben wir müssen die haut von ihr noch
ein bisschen bräuner machen ein bisschen
user muss das so aussehen und dann haben
die einfach nicht nur die haut 5 gemacht
unter dem bauchnabel los mut gemacht
dass ihr einfach weg ist
leute die hat kein brauchen habe ich
hab's auch nicht gesehen so heute schaut
es war das bild hier an
das sind auf jeden fall würde ich also
sagen zwei hübsche attraktive junge
damen die netten party abend zusammen
verbringen und jetzt wahrscheinlich
gleich irgendwie im club gehen oder so
ich war bei dem bild wenn ich sehr
erstaunt jeweils gleich sehen warum aber
was ich erstmal dazu noch sagen muss ich
finde eigentlich schade dass es dieses
mode ideal gibt das wirklich so viele
modezeitschriften oder beauty
zeitschriften hingehen und sagen ey das
model das hat eine kurve zu viele radar
die kugel zu wir das muss genau so
aussehen muss gerade sein oder sonstwas
und jetzt hat euch mal dieses bild jan
wo man sich sofort training alter kraft
das geht mit photoshop ja ich kann es
zwar nicht aber es geht also jetzt dann
vielleicht oben das eine bild und hier
das andere bild oder nebenanlagen keine
ahnung wie viel bekomme ich finds gut so
es ist jetzt zwar kein fail es ist eher
ein meisterwerk aber eher die frage ist
jetzt nur ist da wo die beiden anderen
figuren das original oder was anderes
original also wohl eher etwas
korpulenter sind 2 kommentare ich habe
keine ahnung so weit kommen wir zur
nächsten prominenz die sich jetzt
setzten damals einen fehler erlaubt hat
und zwar ist das lila komme wenn man
hier genau hinschaut sieht man auch ganz
links was ist das da wo die pfeile
hingehen eine lampe oder so und der
spiegel der tür am ich weiß was es ist
auch etwas geboren wo ich mich frage
warum ich mein kommando sie es doch so
gut aus da muss man doch nicht noch ein
ganz kleines bisschen mehr
münster überhaupt der unterschied ich
weiß nicht vielleicht war ihre lage zu
groß oder ihr mund was auch immer
vielleicht sagten die haare nicht
richtig keine ahnung aber das finde ich
dann immer schon so das ist halt dieses
ideal so dass es voll schade für mich
klar facebook benutze ich auch ab und zu
mal aber ich glaube auch viele bilder
hoch wo ich einfach so drauf ausnehmen
wie ich darauf aus die und man muss es
nicht fünf stunden bearbeiten durch
bottrop jahres im irak nicht
irgendwelche filter jahren oder sonst
was das bierzelt mann ist mein englisch
heute und konkreten letzten dame echt
mega stau ich dachte sich heba kommt
vielleicht kann ich an meiner oberweite
ein bisschen was machen das ding ist man
auch im spiegel und vielleicht ein
kleiner tipp das nächste mal du musst
dann natürlich nicht nur dich bearbeiten
sondern auch dein spiegelbild bei sonst
fällt so ein bisschen auch so natürlich
sieht man es nicht so braucht doch man
sieht sofort warum wie wie konnte das
sie muss man doch in jeder normale
mensch sie doch dass da noch was fehlt
damit gleich aussieht ach ja leute ich
will sagen so viel hat man dachte ich
hoffe dass wieder durchgefallen wie
schon gesagt bei 13.500 leicht jetzt
noch ein partner von schick wir dinge zu
bei cnet chat und bei instagram und wird
in uns dann am freitag wieder denken 14
uhr neuen videotext motten label poppins
dabei zu singen oder einfach weil -
xing.com gute sachen ich denke da
gefällt jedem von euch was raus und wir
sehen uns freitag habe ich schon gesagt